hi there steve kaufman
today i'm going to tell you exactly what
i think about language learning i have
in the past sometimes pulled my punches
for those of you who are learning
english pulling your punches means that
you don't say
exactly what you have on your mind you
kind of
try to be a little bit more polite or
politically correct or
whatever but i said to myself here i am
the other day was my 74th birthday today
actually is my wife and
my
my wife's and my our 50th wedding
anniversary tomorrow is canadian
thanksgiving
i'll just let it all hang out i won't go
as far as to give you my views on
politics because that would really
set the cat amongst the pigeons
again an english expression set the cat
amongst the pigeons create a great
flurry of
all kinds of statements here as is
the uh habit on the internet but when it
comes to language learning
i was doing the dishes while listening
to turkish actually
and um but prior to that i had and i was
thinking about something that i had seen
uh a video on facebook where a person
was saying you know everyone has their
own style of learning it's not one size
fits all
and they're sort of learning styles and
of course i have seen a lot of this
literature on
some people are auditory or oral
learners some are visual learners some
are kinetic learners
that has been thoroughly debunked and
yet it remains very popular no
all size uh you know
uh one size does fit all our brains
learn the same way i'm thoroughly
convinced of that our brains learn
through stimulus
largely through input through
predominantly listening and reading now
you may like certain activities you may
like watching movies with
subtitles that you can or movies that
you can't understand or movies with
subtitles and and all of that is is an
exposure at some level to the language
to the culture but it's not an efficient
way of learning
listening and reading listening to
things that you have a chance of
understanding repetitive listening
and eventually as you improve listening
to a broader and broader range of
content and reading that content getting
the language in you that is how you
learn therefore talk from day one is not
an efficient way of learning it does
trigger some
input for you because if you can find
someone to talk to you when you
essentially know nothing in the language
that is input so to the extent that
you're getting input you're learning
however
you're far better off it's far less
expensive far less
intimidating to simply
deal with initially short content as we
do at link repetitive listening and then
moving along to more and more uh
difficult content where you'll encounter
you know more sort of low frequency
vocabulary and you'll just continue
along that road
getting the
the stimulus the experience of the
language into your brain that is the
fundamental learning activity
uh you may not like doing that
you may like uh doing other things but
that is the way you learn now when it
comes to speaking
i firmly believe that in order to speak
well you have to speak a lot but if you
are not in a situation where you have a
lot of opportunity to speak you won't
get enough speaking opportunity to
become a good speaker of the language so
you are better off to spend your time
building up your potential so that when
you have that opportunity you can take
advantage so when i was in japan
learning japanese most of my
learning activity was listening and
reading but every time i had a chance to
use the language i did
now there are people who live surrounded
say by english immigrants and who speak
every day
some
but they don't put enough effort into
listening and reading into deliberately
growing their level of comprehension
their vocabulary they don't read novels
in the language they go home and watch
uh movies and netflix in their native
language they don't give themselves
enough input all right also i consider
grammar exercises to be largely a waste
of time i don't think the the
traditional expectation that because a
teacher teaches something therefore you
should have learned it that doesn't make
sense because our brains learn but they
learn slowly at their own pace and
gradually we get used to aspects of the
language some things we will never get
used to i will never get for example
maybe my case is right in russian or
other you know i watch people who speak
very well speak french very well i saw
jodie foster's has wonderful
pronunciation in french and she gets her
gender wrong a lot i saw the
leadership debate here in canada amongst
our six you know contenders for the
leadership or for the prime ministership
in canada and the three anglophones
spoke french quite well they
communicated quite well but they can't
get the gender right so some things will
never click in or will click in very
very slowly
part of helping those things to click in
is noticing better and we can do a
number of things to improve our ability
to notice and this is where i have some
disagreement with stephen krashen who is
other words otherwise my idol who who
doesn't accept the fact that the ability
to notice is an important part of
language learning it's not that you
there are exercises to help you notice
it's just that i find now as i'm
listening to three languages arabic
persian and turkish and i've been away
from some of them for a while and i
listen to them again afresh
stories that i've listened to before i
noticed things that i didn't notice
before i hear things more clearly you
have to hear the pronunciation in order
to eventually have a chance to repeat
that pronunciation if you don't hear the
pronunciation pronunciation if you don't
notice how these words are in english
for example pronounced that it's
different from how the language is
written if you don't notice these things
you won't have a chance of reproducing
it when you speak so
i just want to get this sort of
there's a lot of well we got everybody
has their own way and we got to be nice
to this person and that person i am
allowed to say what i want because it's
my channel i get to say what i want
people are free to comment as long as
you don't call me names with foul
language i won't block you or you know
delete you you can say what you want but
my channel i think we do a disservice to
people by suggesting that there's every
which way to learn there isn't there is
an issue of what people like to do so if
you don't like to read
you're going to be you're going to have
a tougher time learning you can learn
totally orally it'll be slower because
most people and i i would suspect all
people are helped by being able to see
the written word as well as listen to it
therefore
my advice would be try to develop the
habit of reading read things of interest
start with easy stuff and then grow from
there
if you don't like listening you say you
tune out try to develop that habit
uh my initial sort of involvement with
this whole language exercise which began
about 14 years ago
uh it started when i discovered the at
that time mini this player and having
learned languages throughout my life
using open real uh tape recorders and
cassette tapes
and and sitting in language labs and i
realized wow i can carry this little
thing and it has content there that i
can listen to over and over again i can
have it with me wherever i want i can
download it and all this stuff and of
course the minidiscs player progressed
into the mp3 player but i realized that
this is revolutionary and yeah at first
it may be difficult to listen and we we
fade out and then we fade back in that's
okay
uh but it's something that and some
people say well i can't do the dishes
and listen try to develop that habit
because if your goal is to learn a
language
even if you are living if you are living
where the language is spoken you have
ample opportunity to use it that's great
but still you need to spend a lot of
time getting the language in you the
language doesn't come from within you it
comes from outside and so
obviously if you live in an area where
the language isn't spoken then you have
to spend a lot of your time just
listening and reading you can't spend
your day talking with people via skype
or going to the local you know
arab community and hoping they want to
talk to you they may or may not want to
talk to you
but if you are where the language is
spoken that's great that's great take
advantage of that but still focus on
listening and reading that is the
fundamental way that we learn languages
that's what i wanted to say today
and now my wife and i are going off to
play golf bye for now
[Music]
you